major league baseball moves the all-star
game out of georgia based on media lies
and 60 minutes runs a completely false
hit piece
on florida governor ron desantis i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com speaking of
which if you've been listening to the
show
you know how much cancel culture is a
problem you know how much their big tech
folks really don't like you they don't
like your perspectives but they are
monetizing your data why not deny them
access to that data by using expressvpn
why would you let bigtech cancel your
right to free speech
instead why not cancel their access to
your private data expressvpn can help
you do this have you ever wondered
how these big tech sites make money when
they're actually free to use well they
track your searches video history
everything you click on
and then they sell that valuable data to
third parties when you use expressvpn
your device's ip address gets masked
this helps anonymize your online
activity it makes it much more difficult
to trace and sell to advertisers
expressvpn also encrypts 100 of your
network data to protect you from cyber
criminals and hackers
what i love absolutely most about
expressvpn super simple to use
and when i'm talking about like you open
it on your phone you hit one button and
now you're protected same thing
on your computer it's time to say no to
censorship and take back your
online privacy at expressvpn.com ben
visit my link you get an extra three
months of expressvpn service for free
today that's expressvpn.com
protect your data today expressvpn.com
ben to get started alrighty so over the
weekend major league baseball the
national pastime decided that they would
become just the democratic
pastime they decided they were going to
cancel the all-star game in georgia
this cancellation was based on overt
democratic lies
parroted and forwarded by an
establishment media that are partisan
hacks they are partisan activist liars
this is what they do for a living now
i've been hesitant to use the phrase
enemy of the people because it's a
stalinist phrase
that suggests that people should go to
jail or the people bad things should
happen to people
but let me just say that the media are
the enemies of the truth the
establishment media are just partisan
hacks at this point
they have allowed joe biden and the
biden administration to simply lie
about the content of this georgia voter
law which is more liberal
with regard to early voting than laws in
places like
new jersey its voter id requirement is
utterly uncontroversial
it did not dismantle all ballot drop
boxes or anything like that
ballot dropboxes are a new thing that
were sort of created for the pandemic it
limited the number of those it didn't
get rid of all of them
it expanded in many ways the voting
hours in georgia
this is an extraordinarily mild law in
georgia but that's not what you'd get if
you read your mainstream media if you
read your establishment media what you
would get
is that this was a jim crow attempt to
stop black people from voting that was a
lie
a lie a lie it was a lie all the way
through and joe biden kept saying jim
crow
over and over and over and nobody in the
media saw fitz to fact check that
statement
they would fact-check very specific
statements that joe biden made on
occasion so you get the washington post
giving joe biden four pinocchios for
suggesting that the georgia bill limited
voting hours but
would they overall rate his statement
that this was like a jim crow voting law
of course not
of course not even though it is overtly
a lie you have to be so
unbelievably ignorant and stupid to
believe that this georgia law has
anything to do
with jim crow and yet if you polled
americans i would bet money that half of
americans think that this is jim crow
racism this georgia voter law which
again
is more liberal than delaware state
voting law apparently
so here's what happened joe biden and
the biden administration
and his partners in the media because
that's what they are they are not
objective in any way
they are simply propagandas on behalf of
the democratic party
this partisan hack group decided to push
that lie and not just push that lie
then in activist fashion to try and
pressure private corporations into
pressuring
public bodies like the georgia state
legislature or like the governor of
georgia
so they're trying to mobilize
corporations to do their dirty work for
them they don't have control
of the deliverers of power in georgia so
instead what they're going to do is
they're going to try and get private
corporations
to pressure all these public bodies into
doing what they want now there's a
certain irony to this
members of the left are constantly
saying corporations they shouldn't be
donating money in politics they
shouldn't be in politics like these
corporations with their with their
corporate money
influencing politics and then at the
exact same time they will demand that
these corporations
actively use their businesses right not
just their funds their businesses
themselves they should change how they
do business in order to punish
republican states and so they put a lot
of pressure on major league baseball joe
biden went on espn and he overtly called
for major league baseball to remove the
all-star game from georgia and major
league baseball
and rob manfred who's an abject coward
he's a pathetic abject coward
he's a yellow-bellied coward that that
cowardly ridiculous person
decided you know what that's what we're
gonna do we're gonna pull the all-star
game from georgia
and this follows in the footsteps of
other sports that have done similar
things we saw the ncaa
pull basketball games from north
carolina after a bill that would have
protected
women's bathrooms in charlotte we saw
that there were sports leagues that
attempted to
target arizona in the aftermath of jan
brewer former governor of arizona
pushing the idea that that arizona was
going to enforce immigration law on a
state level
this is nothing new it's just the latest
iteration and it's the most ridiculous
iteration because it is based
on just complete utter lies
again the georgia law is not offensive
for anyone who's actually looked at the
georgia law
the lies about this this bill are insane
the lie that you can't drink water
or be given water if you're 150 feet
from a polling place no you can't have a
partisan activist bring you water but
there are poll workers there and they
will bring you water you can bring water
yourself you can have a friend go get
your water
this is the same law that applies in a
bevy of states but that's not what you
heard
about this law is it what you heard from
stacey abrams who is a liar and joe
biden who is a liar and the media who
are liars
is that this is a jim crow voting tactic
designed to stop black people from
voting
again an overt lie and major league
baseball decided to mirror
that lie okay again these lies were
consistent
over and over and the media just
repeated them
the the washington post reported abram's
abrams actually claimed this is a claim
from stacey abrams again the greatest
politician in american history stacey
abrams she claimed
quote that the georgia gop traded
economic opportunity for suppression
so this was suppression of the vote
okay the washington post by the way did
report on a fact check that experts
consulted by the newspaper said the net
effect was to expand the opportunities
to vote for most georgians not limit
them but that didn't stop the washington
post from simply repeating ad nauseum
joe biden's lines about how this was jim
crow racism
biden said that he would strongly
support the league boycotting the city
over the law that was passed by
democratically elected officials
according to daily wire georgia governor
brian kemp
fought back against all this he said
there's no way we should apologize for
this law are you guys insane there's
nothing wrong with the law
there were mechanical issues that needed
to be fixed
there were reasons to try to figure out
a better way
a more accessible way in a more secure
way
for us to hold elections and there is
nothing wrong with that
we shouldn't apologize for wanting to
make it easy to vote and hard to cheat
then maybe there's an argument for
boycotts and protests and moving
all-star games
but that is not what happened what
happened was
georgia is going to have secure very
accessible
and fair elections in the future in this
state kemp also went ahead and slammed
joe biden
who of course had lied about the georgia
law over and over and over again
it certainly doesn't help when you have
the president of the united states
saying that
and nobody in the national media at
least in the mainstream media will even
ask for a correction when he simply lies
gets a
four pinocchios of all people of all
places from the washington post i mean
that should tell you right there
he's not being truthful he continues to
lie and mislead about what the bill does
so how exactly did this boycott come
about by the mlb
how exactly did major league baseball
america's national pastime decide that
they are simply going to inject
themselves
into american politics on the state
level and punish states on the basis of
democratic lies how did this happen
here's i'll give you that story in just
one second because it truly is
incredible it shows you how a small and
transition group of people along
with the media pushing from the outside
in activist fashion can make this stuff
happen
it really is an amazing amazing thing
we'll get to that in just one second
first
here's a serious issue if you are a
responsible person you need to make sure
that your family is protected in case
god forbid something should happen to
you this is why all responsible people
with dependents
should have life insurance but it used
to be before policy genius you'd have to
do this by word of mouth you'd have to
find a friend the friend would tell you
about their life insurance policy then
you'd end up with a life insurance
policy that was actually not the best on
the market because you couldn't
competitively shop this thing
but policy genius will help you
competitively shop and get the best deal
on your life insurance once you find
your best option policy genius team
will help you set up a new policy for
yourself and answer any questions you
have
along the way you can feel good knowing
your family has financial protection in
case god forbid something should happen
getting started super simple head on
over to policygenius.com
in minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and you can compare
quotes to find your best price since
their licensed agents work for you not
the insurance companies there's no
hassle
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process policy genius will
take care of everything for you soup to
nuts that kind of service has earned
policy genius a five-star rating
across thousands of reviews on
trustpilot and google the best part
all the benefits of policy genius the
comparison tool handling of paperwork
unbiased advice
totally free to use policy genius can
promise you won't leave their website
feeling like a fool you could say 50
or more by comparing life insurance
quotes feel good knowing if something
happens your loved ones will be taken
care of go to policygenius.com to get
started policy genius when it comes to
insurance it's nice and important to get
it right
so how did all of this materialize it
materialized because
just like all corporate blow hardism
basically you have a small intransition
group of people
inside a corporation that have to be
very large
they just be very loud and very
intransigent and they work in inside
outside game with the media
they push from the inside the small and
transient group of folks and then
you have the media pretending that this
represents a broad majority inside the
corporation
and threatening that corporation with
outside action if they refuse
to acknowledge what these wokesters
inside their own halls
want right this is how you get woca cola
you get woca cola because you have a
very small percentage
of employees at woca cola 20 of the
employees
and they decide that they don't like the
georgia law and then you have the media
on the outside yelling at coke
and you have all of the heads of coke
going well you know does it really
matter if we like just say we don't like
the georgia law is that really that big
of a deal we'll just put out a statement
saying we don't like it and then they'll
leave us alone okay this is what
happened with the mlb
with major league baseball and again on
a personal level
i don't have a lot of brand investments
right i don't care if i don't have to if
i don't drink coke it doesn't make any
difference to me i'll drink coke in the
first place i'm not a soda person
but i do care about major league
baseball i'm an enormous baseball fan
i've been an enormous baseball fan
my entire life my father and i wrote a
full-on book about the 2005 chicago
white sox
championship season we we went through
literally every game that season that's
how big a baseball fan
i am i'm a huge huge baseball fan i grew
up with it it's a part of sort of the
lifeblood of the country
and seeing that lifeblood poisoned with
the politics of wokeness
is deeply disturbing it's disturbing on
a number of levels first they're taking
things that we all should be able to
share together and they're wreck and
they're wrecking them they're
politicizing them
but just as importantly they are taking
cherished
aspects of american culture and they are
turning them to politics
and once you do that there's nothing we
share they're making it the left is
making it so there's literally nothing
we share we can't share a baseball game
without getting political we can't pick
a razor brand without getting political
everything is political now and this is
the way they want it this is why when
you hear some conservatives say
why are you so worried about the culture
wars why don't you just worry about the
spending i care about the spending i do
i care about joe biden's crappy bills
we'll get to that
but i care much more deeply about
culture because culture is upstream of
politics a culture
that refuses to acknowledge dissent as
legitimate
a culture that refuses to acknowledge
political diversity a culture that says
you can't work at this corporation
because you voted for trump or that you
can't
you can't have an all-star game in your
state if you voted the way we don't like
that culture is not destined to remain
that is a culture that is destined to
break down
to polarize and then to just collapse in
on itself like a dying star and that's
what we're seeing in the united states
right now
how exactly did major league baseball
again
a coalition of teams with an anti-trust
exemption that should be removed now
how did that coalition of teams with
teams all over the united states
including in red
areas okay georgia despite the fact that
it just elected two blue senators
in a in a bizarre special election
it still is a red state it has a red
legislature it has a red governor
and now after this is going to have two
red senators next time it comes up
how exactly did this league decide that
it was time to just alienate half of its
fan base minimum half of its fan base
commissioner rob manfred according to
espn made the decision to move the
all-star game and events
along with the amateur draft from
atlanta after discussions with
individual big leaguers and the players
alliance an organization of black
players formed after the death of george
floyd last year
this all came together rather quickly
said chicago cubs outfielder jason
hayward who is black
we had i think a day left in spring
training the players alliance we
gathered and got as many people as we
could on a call
it was probably less than 50 guys on
there out of the 100 or whatever
we had our conversation we knew how we
felt about it we wanted to make sure i
think that regardless of what happened
the decision was made and that we were
there to do what we could in atlanta
so number one they promulgated a lie
that the georgia voter law was about
voter suppression it was not and that
was based on a larger lie that democrats
were pushing over the course of the last
few years which is every time they lost
an election it was about suppression of
the black vote it was a lie
it's been a lie it continues to be a lie
this has nothing to do with jim crow has
nothing to do with race and it's
disgusting
i mean really repulsive that the media
parroted that lie and treated it as
legitimate over and over and over
but for our purposes it's just as
important to see that the mlb
shifted its entire stance and removed
according to
the cobb county officials in georgia 100
100 million dollars in revenue from cobb
county
because 45 players in mlb decided to
write a letter rob manfred
i mean that that's unbelievable and
according to daily wire
georgia county that voted for biden will
lose a hundred million dollars
over the mlb relocating the game a
hundred million dollars is removed from
the local economy
people lose their jobs because jason
hayward who makes millions of dollars
for being an overrated baseball player
and some 40 other players decided that
it was deeply necessary
for the mlb to move its all-star game
and rob manfred because he's a coward
decided to go along with it
but was it really about those players
was it really it wasn't only about those
players
it was certainly partially about those
players because those players
were very loud and they were shouting
about racial justice even though again
this had nothing to do with race and it
was based on a lie
but it was about this intransigent woke
minority
inside mlb combined with a media that
was
actively pushing this stuff actively
pushing this stuff
and when i say actively pushing this
stuff let me give you a
an example of just how actively they
were pushing this stuff in just one
second because
this is an ins it shows what the media
are they're an activist propaganda group
on behalf of the democratic party
that's all they are they deserve no more
respect than the normal press release
that you get
from the dnc or from the dnc or from the
the democratic
national campaign committee or from
media matters
they're just an activist group they're a
propaganda outlet they are the pravda of
the democratic party
we'll get to the the proof in the
pudding in just one second first
let's talk about a great gift something
you can do it's amazing for your family
so if you have family if you have
parents grandparents
just your family you want to make sure
that your family memories are preserved
it's such an important thing
nowadays most of us take our pictures on
our phone we have videos on our phone
but
when you were growing up that was not
available obviously you used to take it
on the camcorder and there's little
tapes you pop them in little like vhs
thing nobody has a vcr nobody has one of
those little tapes those things don't
exist anymore
so you've got in your garage boxes of
this stuff what do you do with it it's
just taking up space instead
have it transferred over to a digital
format and save it forever this is what
legacy box does
their service couldn't be simpler you
use their kit to safely send the moments
you want preserved their team will
create digital archive by hand
then you'll receive your new copies
stored on the cloud a thumb drive or dvd
along with all the original media you
sent them with their tracking system you
can follow every single step of the
process so you always know your
originals are being taken care of
i know the people who run legacy box
i've used legacy box myself i did it for
my parents it's an amazing gift they can
now see all the footage from their own
childhood in a way they couldn't before
they sent old film reels they got back
digital format it's fantastic go to
legacybox.com
shapiro join more than a million other
families who have used legacy box for
just a fraction of the regular price
take advantage of 50 off today send in
your legacy box whenever you are ready
go to legacybox.com
shapiro say 50 while supplies last go
check them out
right now okay so here is the proof that
your media are just a bag of flaming
garbage who need to be torn down
okay cbs they're just activists cbs
because it's mlb didn't shift just
because of these woke players these 45
woke players or who or whoever
by the way how many total mlb players
total number
of mlb players right now is
something like a thousand there are a
thousand players on opening day rosters
of the mlb
over a thousand less than 50 players
made the mlb move that
according to espn that's how little the
intransigent minority
has to be in order to reshape the entire
industry it's unreal it's
and that only happens because the media
are who the media are because what do
the media do
what the media do is they then call up
mlb's advertisers
they call up woca cola and they say you
guys advertise with mlb
you just said that you came out against
the georgia bill but i see that you're
advertising
with the mlb who's having their all-star
game in georgia why would you do that
and then woca-cola calls up mlb and they
say you know what it's real awkward for
us why don't you move the all-star game
that's how this little pathetic game
works and the media are in on it
when the media call up coca-cola for
comment they're not calling them for
comment
they're demanding action from coca-cola
because the threat is we are now going
to run a headline
saying that coca-cola is a bunch of
hypocrites this is why number one these
corporations should never give an
inch because once the inch is given they
are done as the minute
you feed a toe to the alligator the rest
of you is gone okay this is the this is
the
the robert shaw seen in jaws the minute
you're sliding down that deck and you're
trying to fend off the shark with your
feet
pretty soon you're gonna find your torso
in its mouth that is what's happening to
all of these corporations
right now so how does he this is the
perfect proof
cbs put out a headline over the weekend
here was the headline it was friday
night
quote three ways companies can help
fight georgia's restrictive new voting
law
does that sound like news to you that
was not in their opinion section
that was not there was no opinion tag or
disclaimer on the article
three ways companies can help fight
georgia's restrictive new voting law
so number one a few problems one it is
not a restrictive new voting law it
expands
voting expands it two so that's just a
lie
two that is a perfectly activist
headline you would see that
from the democratic national committee
you would see that at stacey abrams's
website
three ways companies can help fight
right the implication being if you don't
then you're in favor of georgia's evil
restrictive new voting law
the media are activists if you give them
an iota of respect
it is because you're being a dum-dum
they deserve none of your respect this
doesn't mean
don't watch what they say and then don't
fact-check it you should fact-check it
but if you take what they say at face
value it's because you're a
there's no way that you should be
watching cbs news and taking it at face
value
there's just no way to do it and it's
just mirroring democratic party
priorities that's all they do that's
their actual agenda
why because if the media actually
reported what's going on with mlb it
would be perfectly obvious how
hypocritical
mlb is as fox news reported
it turns out that major league baseball
is protesting that georgia voting law
meanwhile they have bolstered ties with
the communist party-backed chinese
company that cracked down on an nba
executive who
supported the pro-democracy move in hong
kong
the mlb signed a deal with 10 cent on
wednesday it's one of china's largest
tech companies
it's one of the chinese firms that
briefly dropped nba games in 2019
after former houston rockets general
manager daryl mori publicly voiced
support for pro-democracy protesters
facing a beijing backed crackdown in
hong kong
as always it turns out that these sports
teams it's all about the money it's not
about how they are
principled opponents of the georgia
voting law it's because they wish to
avoid
the scrutiny of the media who don't care
at all that all of these corporations
are doing business
with the worst people on earth companies
that are sponsored by the repressive and
tyrannical
chinese government it's just it's an
incredible incredible
that headline my goodness cbs news
eventually pulled it
but the fact that it was even up just
demonstrates where your media are and
they are garbage
by the way speaking of hypocrisy
remember joe biden called for mlb to
move the all-star game
right that's the real reason this
happened joe biden called for it stacey
abrams didn't call for it but basically
said that the georgia voting law is jim
crow
which which promulgated the myth the
media pushed it and then you had just
enough people inside mlb yelling about
it that rob manfred
wimped out because that's what he was
going to do meanwhile jen sackey can't
answer a very simple question
why is it that you're saying company
should boycott georgia but you
the president of the united states the
white house you are not calling for the
united states
to boycott the olympics in china which
it turns out is
you want to know a country that has
really restricted voting laws like super
restricted voting laws not about like
people who are partisan giving water
bottles to people 150 paces from the
voting place
but you know people being sent to
detention camps if they vote the wrong
way
you know china bad voting laws over
there and yet
strangely joe biden seems perfectly
willing to have an olympics in china
when can we expect a final determination
from the president
about the united states participating in
the beijing olympics given that he said
the chinese president doesn't have a
democratic bone in his body
well i think the us olympic committee uh
would play a big role in
uh in on major league baseball here in
the united states he actually
didn't i i think i don't know if you
heard the que the answer the question
the answer that happened a few minutes
ago where we addressed this
and i answered the question so and i
give a little more context but maybe you
weren't paying attention to that part oh
no you're just a liar
you're just a liar you're fine with the
united states doing the beijing olympics
because you don't care if china
represses its own people
but you do care about lying about
georgia so you can presumably win a
bigger share of the black vote by lying
to black voters that jim crow is coming
for them
it's not a shock that the same joe biden
who claimed that mitt romney want to put
black people back in chains
is claiming that a law that expands
voting access in georgia actually
restricts it to hurt black people
they're just damned liars and the media
repeat it they repeat at full scale
now here's the here's the good news
there's going to be a backlash
okay so let's talk about that backlash
for a second here's the reality in
georgia
what's about to happen in georgia is
that rafael warnock is about to lose his
seat okay he is up for re-election
in about a year and a half here not even
right he's
he's up for re-election yeah about a
year and a half november of 2022
he's going to lose his seat he's going
to lose his seat because it turns out
that the people of georgia
only voted for raphael warnock basically
because donald trump intervened in the
georgia senate race
both of those should have gone
republican so that was up there
second it turns out that when you lead a
movement to boycott your own state
that's really unpopular which is why
stacey abrams who is the lead
promulgator of the
overt lie that this is a jim crow
georgia voting bill even she came out
against mlb
she said she blamed republicans for it
she said they prioritized making it
harder for people of color to vote over
the economic well-being of all georgians
like many georgians i am disappointed
the mlb is relocating the all-star game
however i commend the players owner and
league commissioner for speaking out
so in other words she wants it both ways
she's very happy that everybody's
speaking out
and removing the all-star game but also
she's sad they're moving the all-star
game that's because she's
recognizing maybe for the first time
that people losing economic activity
because they disagree with stacey abrams
might not be a great electoral strategy
in a state like georgia
the backlash is coming and it's coming
strong and it should come strong
and there's a piece by dave seminara in
the wall street journal called what i
wouldn't give for a shave that isn't
woke
he says from my closet to my bathroom my
house is full of leftist brands it's
time to do something about it
he says maybe i was wrong to think
conservatives should refrain from
adopting the bullying boycotting tactics
of the left i made the case
against emulating progressives in these
pages last summer as i lamented the rise
of the woke corporation
documenting how many of my favorite
companies embraced values antithetical
to my own but it's increasingly clear
that the sharp increase in corporate
virtue signaling after george floyd's
death wasn't a passing trend but a sea
change
perhaps it's time for conservatives to
boycott companies that hate us
yes this is correct it's time for
companies to form on the right
in direct opposition to this stuff we're
going to be doing that at daily wire i
promise you it's coming
we're going to be forming companies that
are specifically designated in order to
take on the woke culture in corporate
america
and you should do the same okay if this
is the country that the left wants
this is the country they're going to get
they're going to get a backlash in
georgia electorally and in the culture
sphere
people on the conservative side of the
aisle are gonna start businesses that do
not cater to the woke that decide
they're gonna cater to everybody and
they're gonna just tell the woke to
shove it because here's the dirty little
secret the woke
don't have that much power the media are
a paper tiger the media yelling at you
and saying how they're gonna boycott you
and they're gonna be mean to you no one
gives a crap
no one gives a crap the the dirty secret
of the media is that they are a mirage
the media have a perception of power
because they can drive narrative
but not enough people pay attention to
the narrative to actually make a
difference it's just these corporate
leaders are so
online they're so on twitter that
they're afraid of seven people on
twitter
we know this for example because harry's
razors decided to cancel advertising
with some of the shows on daily wire
because one of the daily wire hosts
made the crazy statement that a man is a
man and a woman is a woman and you're
not allowed to say that so harry's razor
was like this doesn't agree with our
values
okay well you know fine fine you don't
like us you don't like our listeners
that's fine harry's razors we'll just
launch a different brand of razors
and our people can go to us because
guess what
two can play at this game i've said for
a long time i don't like boycott tactics
i'm not a fan of them
but there's only one thing worse than
boycott tactics
and that is letting the other side use
them and then being victimized by them
there's only one thing worse than having
nuclear weapons
and that is the other guy having nuclear
weapons and you being completely
disarmed
the right is not going to stand for this
any longer nor should they
the blowback is coming and it's going to
come very strongly and the more the
media just let it out of the closet
exactly
what they are the more the blowback is
coming and it's going to come against
the media too
there's a reason that right-wing media
are growing and they will we will
continue to grow here at daily wire
because
people don't want to get their news from
a bunch of partisan hacks who won't
announce that they are even partisan we
here at the daily wire acknowledge we're
conservative
i've told you i mean i've told you go
listen to positive america go listen my
show and then
where we agree on the fact pattern
that's the fact everything else is
opinion
and nobody on the left will do that
because they are liars because they lie
about their own agenda it's not just
they lie about the facts
they lie about their own agenda i don't
lie about my agenda you know my agenda
the moment you set foot
in the in hearing range of the show but
the media just lie to you
and they lie consistently and they lie
with narrative
it's happening over and over and over
another example so
over the weekend there was a rather
major story
but it's not a major story because
here's the way it works when it comes to
crime stories
if there is a crime story that backs the
media narrative that america is
systemically racist and evil
and filled with white supremacist
right-wingers then that's a national
story
if a person who is not moving along with
that narrative commits a murder
in a high-profile fashion that's not a
national news story that's a local news
story
so if a white person kills a black
person on the street that's a national
story because it underscores the idea
that america is evil and systemically
racist and how could we be such a
terrible country if a black person kills
a white person on the street
which in terms of statistical
probability is actually more likely to
happen
that's not a national story that's a
local news story
okay if you perfect example over the
weekend
it turns out that there was a an attack
on the us capitol police
a member of us capitol police was killed
by a person who drove a car
into the into two us capital police
officers
then got out of his vehicle with a knife
and then he was shot by the police
the immediate response by the media by
many of the media was this has to be
some
sort of white supremacist right this has
to be a q anon guy or something well it
turns out not
it turns out that the that the attacker
was a 25 year old black man who was a
follower of louis farrakhan's nation of
islam
this person's facebook page describes
himself as a follower of farrakhan
in which he said that farrakhan was
jesus
he uh said that he was his spiritual
father and he called himself noah x
many twitter accounts initially rushed
to assume the attack was carried out by
a white supporter
of former president trump but the minute
that it turned out that this was a louis
farrakhan supporter boom it was gone
from the media you haven't heard about
it at all
you haven't heard about it all just as
many police officers were killed
this week at the u.s capitol as were
killed on january 6th
and there was there's one police officer
we still don't know how he died we don't
know if he was murdered at the capitol
but
officer brian sicknick died maybe
presumably i mean again the facts are
still coming out
during the january six attacks and over
a u.s capital police officer was just
murdered over the weekend
it is not a national news story because
of the identity of the perpetrator the
media have decided it's not a national
news story
because they are partisan hacks because
all they care about is the democrat
leaning narrative
and let me just tell you this if that
had been a donald trump supporter every
republican in
america would have been asked about how
your vote for donald trump
effectuated this kind of thing but this
person was a follower of louis farrakhan
will a single democrat who's met with
louis farrakhan be asked about this
well a single democrat who's made nice
with louis farrakhan i'm talking about
representative hank johnson i'm talking
about rashida talib i'm talking about
ilhan omar i'm talking about
all the democratic members who have been
warm with figures from nation of islam
will any of those people be asked at
all about their association with with a
person
of that ideology no don't be silly
don't be silly because that of course is
a local news story
in a second we're going to get to the
biggest media battery of the day i mean
it's just
the media are they are out and they are
proud and they're living life to the
fullest
the backlash is going to be
extraordinary and i cannot wait for it i
am here for it
and that's the biggest media butchery of
the day it is purposeful butchery
it is frankly defamat its defamation and
if they weren't targeting a public
figure they'd find themselves in court
we'll talk about that in just one second
first let us talk about the fact that
you really don't want to go to the post
office these days or
you know kind of ever the post office is
great but why would you want to stand in
line
in order to get the services of the post
office when you could just do the same
thing from home
that's why i recommend mailing and
shipping online at stamps.com
stamps.com allows you to mail and ship
anytime anywhere right from your
computer you can send letters ship
packages and pay a lot less with
discounted rates from usps ups and more
stamps.com and save businesses thousands
of hours and tons of money with
stamps.com you get the services of the
post office in ups
all in one place here at daily wire
we've been using stamps.com since 2017
because we care about saving time
and saving money simply use your
computer to print official us postage 24
7 for any letter any package any class
email anywhere you want to send it
once your mail is ready schedule a
pickup drop it off with stamps.com
you get discounts up to 40 off post
office rates up to 62
off ups shipping rates it's a no-brainer
stop wasting your time
going to the post office go to
stamps.com instead there's no risk
with my promo code shapiro you get a
special offer it includes a four week
trial plus
free postage and digital scale no
long-term commitments no contracts just
go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage type in shapiro that is
stamps.com
promo code shapirostamps.com never go to
the post office
again alrighty in just a second we're
going to get to the worst media butchery
of the day and it is purposeful
it is purposeful malicious media
batchery we'll get to that in just one
second first
as we return from easter and passover
it's important to reflect on the impact
these holidays have on our faith
the impact that judeo-christian values
have on our culture more and more the
left wants to erase those values replace
them with their own pseudo-morality
it's one of the reasons we've launched a
brand new talk show with candace owens
one of the fiercest protectors of
conservative values and free speech
but behind the headlines and twitter
fights see candace as herself funny
political
insightful you're gonna love her show
watch her host lively discussion panels
exclusive interviews with an always
exciting round of guests
candice is the first daily wire show to
appear in front of a live studio
audience
an element that's rarely been seen in
conservative media it commenced our
commitment to fighting for the culture
it's a different kind of show whatever
the left does we
on the right we can do it better the
show streams on fridays 9 pm eastern 8
pm central at dailywire.com
you can get the audio podcast canvas on
apple spotify or wherever you listen to
your podcast so if you need some candace
owens in your podcast feed
look no further head on over to apple
podcast or spotify subscribe today be
sure to leave a five star review
if you like what you hear you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
alrighty so let's talk about the worst
media butchery of the day and it is not
a mistake okay this is not
just them being bad at journalism it is
that they are hacks they are partisan
hacks
with an agenda this is deliberate these
are propagandists 60 minutes ran a
propaganda piece about florida governor
ron desantis now desantis has been the
target of the media ever since the
beginning of the pandemic
because desantis took a different
strategy than california and new york
and he showed them up
he made them look really bad it turns
out that desantis ran this state
beautifully the state that i am in
well new york and california ran their
states like garbage
andrew cuomo shipped covered positive
patients back into nursing homes he
killed thousands of them and covered it
up
in california they shut down the entire
state for a full year and ended up with
the same deaths per million ratio as
florida despite the fact that california
has one of the youngest populations in
america and florida
has the oldest population in america
outside of maine okay but the media hate
desantis because desantis didn't listen
to their pathetic lies about covid and
how to treat covet and all the rest of
it
desantis knew coveted was a threat he
was a threat that mostly centered on
elderly people and so he protected the
elderly and he told everybody else to go
out and use risk assessment
and wear masks when they felt that they
were at risk and then live their lives
he didn't destroy the economy he didn't
prevent people from living their lives
he didn't kill all the restaurants he
didn't prevent people from eating
outdoors the way they did in california
desantis handled it right cuomo and
newsome handled it wrong the media
like cuomo and they like newsom so since
the beginning of the pandemic they've
been covering every idiotic story out of
florida
and then never doing follow-up to show
that they were wrong so they'll have
some lawyer
walking around the beaches of
jacksonville dressed up as the grim
reaper
and saying like wow look at this guy
he's shaming ron desantis they'll never
follow up to point out that no one
actually got coveted on the jacksonville
beach
they'll have story after story about how
look at ron desantis and tampa i mean
they have the super bowl there surely
there will be a massive outbreak no
massive outbreak no follow-up
and well now they're trying to suggest
that desantis is corrupt so
a couple weeks ago they just put like
last week they put out a story the media
that was a lie
that desantis was covering up deaths and
it turns out that the person who
authored the study they were drawing
from said that the media were lying
about it
it's okay they've promoted the idea of
hashtag death santas it doesn't matter
all that matters is the narrative it
doesn't matter that the excess death
numbers that were being used in flora
were the same as the excess death
numbers everywhere else
it doesn't matter the sans is the bad
guy so 60 minutes tried to generate
a headline last night with a story that
is just complete bullcrap it's just not
true
and of course drudge report which has
basically just become the huffington
post
you may have noticed this it's pretty
incredible right drudge who used to be
a fairly conservative libertarian voice
his headlines are now indistinguishable
from huffington post indistinguishable
the headline over at drudge right now is
desantis accused of pay for play in
vac's rollout
grocery chain gave pack a hundred
thousand dollars okay so
here is what their supposed story is at
60 minutes their supposed story is
that ron desantis allowed publix to hand
out the vaccine
the grocery chain publix to hand out the
vaccine because they gave him a hundred
thousand dollars in his super pac
okay there's only one problem with the
story it's not true
it's not true that's not why he allowed
publix to do it
he didn't cvs and walgreens had the vac
i know i was here cvs and walgreens had
the vaccine first
the they were insufficient at pushing
out the vaccine so local officials said
why not give it to publix
lots of there are 800 publics around the
state of florida what if publix were
able to do it
and it sounds like hey that's a good
idea let's do it
publix gives money to politicians on
both sides of the aisle it's a grocery
chain
you think ron desantis was corruptly
using publix to
accelerate the role what was supposed to
do not accelerate the role out of the
vaccine
in the oldest state in america okay so
it's not just that 60 minutes botches
the story by the way democratic
officials say that they botched the
story
democratic state officials said it's
it's false and offensive
according to daily wire the segment
featured reporter sharon alfonsey
ambushing desantis at a press conference
last month
aggressively questioning him using a
misleading narrative about the way he
has responded to the covered pandemic
alfonsi tried to suggest that publix the
largest grocery store chain in florida
had exchange had engaged in pay to play
by donating money to desantis's campaign
in exchange for being awarded a contract
to distribute vaccines in the state
publix put out a statement they said the
irresponsible suggestion there is a
connection between campaign
contributions made to governor desantis
and our willingness to join other
pharmacies
in support of the state's vaccine
distribution efforts is absolutely false
and offensive
we're proud of our pharmacy associates
for administering more than 1.5 million
doses of vaccine to date and for joining
other retailers in alabama florida
georgia south carolina tennessee and
virginia
to do our part to help communities
emerge from the pandemic former florida
state representative jared moskowitz a
democrat
slammed 60 minutes saying desantis's
office did not push for selecting publix
moskowitz is director of the florida
division of emergency management
and has overseen the state's response to
the pandemic
60 minutes he said i said this before
i'll say it again publix was recommended
by the florida division of emergency
management and the florida department of
health as the other pharmacies were not
ready to start
period full stop no one from the
governor's office suggested publix it's
just absolute malarkey this is a
democratic official
it's a democratic official okay so what
did 60 minutes do in order to generate
this fake narrative so there's this
exchange about a month ago between
sharon alfonse and ron desantis here is
how 60 minutes cut the exchange
okay here's it i'm going to show you how
they cut the exchange then i'm going to
show you the full exchange
they cut out the part where's the census
explained why she was lying and wrong
they just cut it out
completely to make it look like he was
just being randomly combative here was
so here's the fake exchange from 60
minutes the selectively edited exchange
then i'm gonna play the full exchange
here's the selectively edited one
i met with the county mayor i met with
the administrator i met with all the
folks at palm beach county and i said
here's some of the options we can do
more drive-through sites we can give
more to hospitals
we can do the publix and they said we
think that would be the easiest thing
for our residents
but melissa mckinlay the county
commissioner in the glades told us
the governor never met with her about
the public's deal
the criticism is that it's paid a place
it's wrong it's wrong it's a fake
narrative
i just disabused you of the narrative
and you don't care about the facts
okay and so everyone's like oh look at
that combative ronda sanchez
look at him all the experts from the
lincoln project when they were
not busy covering up for for people who
were abusing
male staffers they were like look at the
experts look at rhonda sanchez want to
come back
he he is a liar okay here is the full
exchange
because we have tape of it here's the
full exchange 60 minutes sliced out
the entire explanation by desantis of
why sharon alfonse is just lying and
wrong
they just cut it out because he made her
look like a fool here was the entire
exchange
first of all when we did the the first
pharmacies that had it were cvs and
walgreens
and they had a long-term care mission so
they were going to the long-term care
facilities
they got vaccine in the middle of
december they started going to the
long-term care facilities
the third week of december to do ltc's
so that was their mission
that was very important and we trusted
them to do that
as we got into january we wanted to
expand the distribution points
so yes you had the counties you had some
drive-through sites you had hospitals
that were doing a lot
but we wanted to get it into communities
more so we reached out to other retail
pharmacies publix walmart
obviously cvs and walgreens had to
finish that mission and we said we're
going to we're going to use you as soon
as you're done with that
for the publix they were the first one
to raise their hand say they were ready
to go
okay and he does this full explanation
he says
he says they calculated 90 of their
seniors live within a mile and a half of
a publix they said we think that would
be the easiest thing for our residents
so we did that and what ended up
happening was you had 65 publix in palm
beach palm beach is one of the biggest
counties one of the most elderly
counties we've done almost 75
of the seniors in palm beach and the
reason is because you have a strong
retail footprint so our weight has been
multi-faceted it has worked and we're
also now very much expanding cvs and
walgreens now that they've completed
that long-term care mission okay that
was that was his full explanation
just cut all of it out just cut all of
it out to make it look like he was not
telling the truth
his own officials right democrats are
saying that
he's telling the truth and 60 minutes is
lying she should be fired for this she
should lose her job this selective
editing
is a hit piece it is a hit piece from 60
minutes
and it's being now laundered into the
public press is being laundered by the
media
so here's how axios covers this quote
florida governor clashes with 60 minutes
over kova vaccine rollout oh it's just a
clash
it's just a clash why it matters
desantis has been criticized for
directing vaccines toward wealthy
communities
with some who benefited from the vaccine
pop-ups also donating to the governor's
political action committee
okay that was a lie as well the idea
that desantis was just giving vaccines
to the rich
no he was putting it where the old
people are the old people in florida
happen to be in the richer communities
generally
that is ridiculous of course he was
giving the vaccines to the old the olds
were the ones dying of kovid what was he
supposed to do give it to people who
were poor and young
made no sense at all they pushed that
narrative so they've now tried several
different narratives to try and nail
desantis because they see desantis as a
possible 2024 contender so trying to
knock him out early first they promoted
the lying narrative that by having the
state open at all he was killing people
it was not true
then they tried to promote the narrative
that ron desantis was in corrupt fashion
rolling out the vaccines only for his
political rich allies
wrong he was rolling it out for the
elderly then they tried to promote the
narrative that ron desantis was covering
up the cove numbers that was also a lie
and finally they are now promoting the
narrative that ron desantis for a
hundred thousand dollar donations from
publix decided that he was going to
allow you know the largest grocery chain
in florida to hand out the vaccine and
this is treated not only as legit news
but as driving the news driving the news
okay according to axios the 60 minutes
program highlighted reports of vaccine
favoritism with florida's poorer
communities being left behind in the
rollout
there's no publix in belle glade in palm
beach county oh so they found a town
where there's no publix to suggest that
now
using the most the most branched
grocery in the state is a bad thing
you know how stupid that is so you find
the grocery that's the most common in
the entire state
you say you know what you guys should
hand out the vaccine so what did 60
minutes do they went to a community that
doesn't have a branch
and then they're like you know what
because this community doesn't have a
publix
no public should have it the hell are
you talking about
state democratic representative omari
hardy told the show you have lots of
folks who don't have cars in the
community it's a round trip of over two
hours with 34 stops to the nearest
publix 25 miles away
publix isn't the only outlet handing
this out cvs and walgreens are also
handing it out
and there are state pop-ups getting out
the vaccine
again this is all it's just wrong it's a
lie
it's just not true but it doesn't matter
because 60 minutes
drives the narrative because the media
are driving the narrative and they're
just
absolute disgusting partisan hacks you
should not trust them with an iota of
your time with an iota of your money you
shouldn't trust any narrative they push
they're out of the closet propagandas on
behalf of the democratic party just
trying to push joe biden to a second
term on a gurney
it's unreal and they'll do it any way
they can
take for example the unbelievable
coverage of hunter biden's new book so
hunter biden has now put out a book
okay his book is an attempt to cash in
on the fact that he's a garbage human
okay this has nothing to do with joe
hunter's being a garbage human
is not on joe it's on hunter hunter is a
garbage human by every
by every specification he's a long time
crack cocaine addict
who used to mess around with strippers
impregnated one had her get a paternity
test
the the child never really comes up in
his book like none of this
he's a bad he all he does is run around
picking up bags of cash
on behalf of uh because he has a last
name that's biden hunter is just a bad
person
if you follow his life story there's no
question he's just if you follow his
text messages
he's but the media have been in steady
cover-up mode for hunter biden being a
bad person because they're afraid it's
going to reflect badly on joe which is
unbelievable they could just say listen
hunter is garbage joe's fine they can't
do that instead it has to be
hunter biden story doesn't even exist
the hundred by the laptop story
disinformation
russian disinformation well now hunter
biden has acknowledged
that that that laptop is probably his
and the media are like whoa same media
saying it was a non-story
now they're like he has a new book out
and you know it's a moving and wonderful
book
it's a moving and incredible book except
that the book is basically a cover-up
except that the book basically excuses
him
for his own activity doesn't really talk
about that
that the fact that he was scoring deals
to get on the board of amtrak
and scoring high paying gigs consulting
and the media treat him with just
absolute kid gloves
he has no answers but they'll they'll
treat him credibly here's hunter biden
talking with cbs news saying you know
i'm cooperating with the doj i'm a nice
guy
there's a current department of justice
investigation into your finances
what is it about can you say anything i
can't but
i can say this is i'm cooperating um
completely
and i am absolutely certain 100 certain
that at the end of the investigation
that i will be cleared of any wrongdoing
you're 100 i'm 100
certain of it and all i can do is
cooperate
and and trust in the process sure
sure yeah by the way the book is being
covered as a wonderful piece of
literature that's how they're covering
it
hunter biden bears his soul bears his
soul that's the story not that hunter
biden is a scuzz bucket who just picked
up two million dollar advance from simon
schuster
for basically lying about his own
history unreal
alrighty we will be back here later
today with an additional hour of content
in the meantime go check out the michael
noll show where he discusses easter
lockdowns you can hear more details
about this story over on michael's show
that is available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
a canadian pastor teaches americans a
thing or two about freedom
and religion mlb gets woke er
and charles barkley sees what's really
going on in race relations check it out
on the michael knowles show